et pour en parler en direct avec nous
sur ce plateau claude blanchemaison une
expert en relations internationales quad
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
c'est un plaisir de vous accueillir
alors cette défaite électorale est ce
que c'est un coup dur pour boris johnson
oui ça arrive au mauvais moment parce
que effectivement origines sonne et face
à un certain nombre de scandales on peut
le dire probablement que le plus récent
est en effet celui de la petite fête au
thème d'un district l'année dernière au
moment de noël où effectivement à un
moment où les anglais était interdit de
se rencontrer en toute candeur du cadre
strictement familial
eh bien on a organisée semble-t-il dans
la dans les bureaux du premier ministre
une petite fête peut être une autre un
peu plus tôt ou un peu plus tard aussi
au siège du parti conservateur et la
faute dans le fond de boris johnson et
d'avoir nié au parlement donc il aurait
menti puisque sa collaboratrice attaché
de presse acp dans le fond reconnu les
faits en démissionnant et et en
s'expliquant de façon un petit peu
confuse devant les journalistes qui
l'interrogeaient donc mentir devant
devant le parlement s'est pas c'est pas
bien en grande bretagne est quelque
chose qui normalement a des conséquences
alors les conséquences c'est pour boris
johnson puisque évidemment le parti
conservateur à une très large majorité
la question est de savoir quand un
certain nombre de membres du parlement
qui appartiennent au parti conservateur
demanderont au leadership de ce parti de
faire démissionner boris johnson et de
le remplacer comme premier ministre le
moment n'est pas encore venu d'ailleurs
ça donnera sans doute lieu à une
compétition entre les candidats mais
probablement qu'après les fêtes de fin
d'année est ce cet événement se produira
et que le parti conservateur pour
conserver son crédit en fait dans le
pays
remplacera boris johnson d'autant plus
qu' on l'a vu sur votre sujet les
indépendantistes écossais commence à
bouger d'autant plus qu'il ya un
contentieux avec l'union européenne qui
n'est pas du tout régler et qui est
grave
pour nous celui de la pêche les pour
l'union européenne globalement celui de
la du contrôle des marchandises qui
arrivent en irlande du nord actuellement
il n'ya pratiquement pas de contrôle
elle passe librement en république
d'irlande ce qui veut dire que le marché
unique à un grand trou qu'il ne
fonctionne pas normalement oui ça va mal
hein pour boris johnson les accords sur
les licences de pêche et accord sur
l'irlande du nord ce pot de noël dont
vous parliez hautaine downing street et
puis il ya aussi sa majorité boris
johnson qui ne va pas forcément dans le
même sens que lui tout le temps oui
mardi 99 députés tories ont refusé le le
pass sanitaire sous prétexte que ceux-ci
portent atteinte à la sacro sainte
liberté individuelle en grande bretagne
qui a toujours pas de carte d'identité
individuelle on tient beaucoup à cette
liberté de chaque personne et boris
johnson a été obligée de recourir à des
votes du parti travailliste pour
compenser cette défection d'une centaine
de députés conservateurs pour faire
passer quand même son son projet donc en
effet c'est un peu une situation qui
devient
difficile sinon désespérée pour le
premier ministre lui-même mais encore
une fois la
situation du parti conservateur en tant
que telle n'est pas menacée puisque il
ya bénéficie d'une très large majorité
lors boris johnson le dire il assume
pleinement sa responsabilité dans cette
défaite qu'est ce que ça veut dire
comment petit différent pour récurer
vous récupérer la confiance de ses
partisans il n'a pas le choix sur le cas
particulier de de la défaite dans une
circonscription bas particulière et
effectivement il doit bien l'assumer
mais je pense qu'il sera surtout attaqué
par ses collègues sur les autres sujets
c'est à dire que dans le fond en signant
l'accord sur le bric site dans la forme
où il l'a signé et l'a conduit à une
impasse une double impasse sur la sphère
de l'irlande du nord tout le monde est
d'accord pour qu' il n'y ait pas de
rétablissement de frontières entre
l'irlande du nord et la république
d'irlande c'est le coeur de l'accord du
vendredi saint qui a permis la paix le
retour à la paix mais effectivement il
ya un désaccord maintenant entre le
gouvernement britannique boris johnson
et l'union européenne sur la manière d'y
parvenir et boris johnson tient à
l'unité du marché de la deûle à lille du
royaume-uni de grande-bretagne par
conséquent ne veut pas établir ces
contrôles qui sont pourtant prévu dans
un traité qui la fille est donc ça va
être un peu à peu difficile et on voit
bien aussi que le président de la
république française a dit il ya dans
une conférence de presse récente dans le
fond sur l'europe qu'il souhaitait avoir
de bons rapports avec la grande bretagne
qu'il était lui-même l'ami du peuple
britannique
sous-entendu vivement un autre premier
ministre oui pis en plus ça va être
compliqué d'établir de bonnes relations
sa chambre on vient d'apprendre en paris
l'a confirmé avait engagé un contentieux
auprès de la commission européenne
concernant ces licences de pêche alors
cette affaire de la pêche effectivement
et et elle peut l'enjeu économique est
très faible mais l'enjeu sur le plan des
des personnes des pêcheurs de la côte
normande évidemment est très important
et en année électorale il est impossible
que le gouvernement français fasse des
concessions sur ce sujet il faut que le
gouvernement britannique et le
gouvernement les gouvernants les îles
anglo-normandes délivre les licences de
pêche telles qu'elles sont prévues dans
les accords même si certains pêcheurs
artisanaux ne sont pas en état de
prouver parce qu'ils sont pas équipés d
d d d d instruments nécessaires qu'ils
sont des pêcheurs traditionnels au large
de jersey au large de guernesey et on en
est là probablement que cette partie du
traité n'a pas été rédigé de façon
suffisamment précise puisqu'il existait
un traité de granville depuis années
2000 qui réglait ce sort des pêcheurs
traditionnels dans les deux sens
d'ailleurs fait à dire que ceux de
jersey en france et de ceux de la côte
normande au large des côtes de jersey
blanchemaison il est difficile de pas de
ne pas parler de mikron au royaume y
d'ailleurs les conseiller scientifique
au gouvernement britannique qualifie
cette vague au micro d' inquiétante 1 de
phénoménal
qu'est-ce que son coeur pour le royaume
uni qui alors là aussi ça sera
probablement porter au débit de boris
johnson
comme effectivement toute crise
sanitaire peut l'être au débit des lieux
dada gouvernement et la boris johnson
sans doute à sous-estimer les les
problèmes sous-estimé les difficultés là
cette fois ci je crois qu'il n'a
vraiment pas de chance puisque cette
vague devient incontrôlable et qu'elle
oblige la grande-bretagne à s'isoler du
reste du reste de l'europe et du reste
du monde d'ailleurs pour parler de
sous-estimation est-ce qu'il n'a pas un
peu trop sous-estimé au début de la
vague épidémique locaux vides dans les
sauts johnson je crois qu'il a trop
confiance en lui et que il pense que
avec
sa bonhomie ses bonnes blagues la façon
qu'il a son empathie il peut régler les
problèmes
et effectivement il n'a pas la
réputation de travailler suffisamment
sur les dossiers et à dire sur les sur
les sujets eux mêmes dont il a sans
doute en effet sous-estimé les
difficultés réelles sur tous les sujets
qu'on a évoqué est surestimé sa capacité
à
renverser la table et à obtenir des
désaccords un petit peu à l'arraché
claude blanchemaison merci en tout cas
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales mercier vous